[Music]
[Applause]
everyone this is steve weintraub i'm
editor-in-chief of the website collider
and i am super super happy to have joe
and anthony russo with me
for our ccxp worlds panel uh gentlemen
how are you both doing
good how are you sir so good to see you
uh i am doing great listen um i know we
have a limited amount of time and i want
to jump
right on in uh you guys obviously have a
production company you are essentially
studio heads with agbo
and we have so many different things to
talk about uh but i want to start with
uh sort of quick updates on a number of
different things
uh just a little while ago i think even
a few days ago it was announced that you
guys were going to be doing
um saigon bodyguards with chris pratt
and um chinese superstar wu jin
i believe that's how you pronounce his
name um can you sort of talk about how
did that project come together
sure we've been looking for something to
be with chris for a while
um obviously we're very close to him
from the work that we did over the last
few years with marvel
and mujin and we are close to because of
the
uh world war ii that that we helped him
out on and
uh he and chris knew each other and
we're looking for a project together and
we thought this would be a good
a good pairing of their chemistry
right kind of story to tell i want to do
a big fun genre action
uh thriller uh can you discuss or reveal
where you are in the development process
on this
super early i mean we literally are just
you know just
nascent script stage
[Music]
got it let's move on to the next thing
uh you guys are doing a hercules remake
uh what's the status of that movie
that we're uh we have an incredible
writer on it dave calahan and we're he's
off on script
we i should be seeing something in the
next week or two i think
i think you've talked about this but
will there be songs what can you tease
about your
remake we're keeping that all under
wraps for now
uh yeah we'll uh you know we want the
audience to have some discoveries about
what's fresh about our tape to be fair
we're still in the process of finding it
you know it it these are these are
projects that are early in the early
days and there's a long road of
sort of creative experimentation that
goes on before we
really know what the movie is so
something else you guys have been
working on
um is citadel um what can you say about
this project
and uh let's let me stop there yeah
cinderella's about two months away from
yeah on camera
uh if the scripts are incredible cast
amazing we're really happy with that
show
and it's a and it's an experimental um
uh you know world that we're creating
here where we're gonna be
doing a massive flagship show and then
some smaller
regional shows built around the flagship
show and
um there'll be foreign language shot by
local
new talent that we discover and support
um
and so we're really excited about
citadel and it's it's prospects for what
it can do for
you know trans media concepts and
shaping the way that people view content
in the future and consume stories which
is
always exciting to us i was just going
to add about citadel that
you know it's it's a very um
it's a very ambitious project i don't
know that anything like it has been
attempted yet
uh with television we give amazon a lot
of credit
uh for wanting to be partners in a grand
sort of
narrative experiment like this where
we're we're telling a very
interwoven global narrative that
involves several concurrent series
running at the same time and it's it's
uh it's it's something we're extremely
excited about uh
it's always fun to be uh attempting
something
on a on a storytelling level that's
never been done before and i think
citadel falls in that category
for people that aren't familiar with it
can you give like a log line or what is
it about
a little bit more specifically yeah it's
a
it's a new world spy thriller and
with a very strong high concept at the
center of it
it's it's uh it's it's a fascinating
character study at the same time as a
as it's a massive canvas you know
action um story so uh it's a really
unique
um universe and uh really unique
collection characters
we're really excited to share i heard
about exit west i don't know if you guys
are still doing it
um but so are you guys still working on
exit west
we're still working on it we we are
developing the
it's a favorite book of ours and we are
uh
uh barack and michelle obama are also
sort of
uh producing the movie with us and we're
in script phase again with that movie uh
early phase
but um we're very excited about it it's
an incredible novel
and we're very excited about how we
translate that to film
[Music]
it has a crazy log line what that what
that book is about
for people that aren't familiar can what
can you say i would just say it's a
you know it's it's a it's a love story
set
within the sort of global um
refugee world that has an element of
magical realism to it
that takes us into a whole new
experience a whole new understanding of
that crisis
and it's it's a really beautiful
inspiring story that you know we
couldn't be more excited about
i think it couldn't be more relevant to
like the experience that we're all going
through today
uh you guys are also developing a
cambridge analytica movie
um where is that in the development
spectrum
marcus and mcfeely wrote an incredible
script i think it's the best script
they've ever written
uh and we're just packaging that you
know putting putting an actor and
director on it
and getting ready to go it'll be
interesting post the election
uh i think that there's going to be a
lot of um
fascination with um cambridge analytica
if you've seen them
uh in your netflix documentary about
social media um this is uh this is a
world that uh
you know we've opened the pandora's box
and um
it's gonna be interesting to see if we
can close it or contain it
and otherwise i think the internet may
have a field day with our
brains obviously everyone watching
loves your work on the marvel movies and
that's you know
um you did such a fantastic job i'm
curious
obviously marvel is always going to hire
new directors to helm
future projects they're you know they
there's so many different people working
on them
for for someone helming their first mcu
movie
joining the fold if you will what advice
might you share
um about your experiences working on
these movies that you'd sort of pass on
to someone else
like our experience with marvel was we
couldn't have better partners you know
they're
incredibly collaborative they are
sort of they push you in all the best
ways i mean marvel is never happier than
when you
sort of think to the table that they
weren't already thinking of
and that's when they get most excited so
i would just say dig deep
on sort of what inspires you about the
story you want to tell
and sort of swing for the fences with it
you don't have a
there's no better partner out there to
support you in terms of your biggest
dreams and biggest aspirations in terms
of what you want to do cinematically
so it's um i'd say just go for it
yeah i mean i think that azan said the
greatest group of people you could ever
hope to work with uh and you know bring
a strong point of view
uh to the movie and what do you you know
this is
it's a collective uh um artwork
you know and uh what are you bringing to
it that can change it or shift it in a
direction
or excite people or surprise people uh
you know what what
identity and you know singular identity
can you bring to it
that uh that adds to the the mosaic
of that's the marvel universe
uh you guys during the pandemic uh did
something called
uh uh i wanna say it right pizza film
school and you did weekly episodes
with um on some of these classic movies
but for me i think
um you guys had mark hamill talking
about empire strikes back
obviously you've worked with some of the
biggest movie stars
and you've had this amazing already this
amazing career
how much are you still when you have
mark hamill
on and you're talking to him about
empire strikes back
do you sort of forget about all your
success and just become little kids
again
or you know what i mean 100 i always say
that
we've met so many actors over our career
that you know the ones that always get
you the most
nervous are the ones that that you
idolize as children
because you associate those childlike
emotions with that person
so whenever you meet somebody iconic
like our camel was so influential
on your childhood uh it's a it's a giddy
moment
and that was you know a lot of that was
just anthony and marcus mcfeely
for two episodes just staring at mark
hamill and all
listening to all the incredible stories
he had to tell
yeah i mean it's exactly like joe just
described and we could have
listened to like mark hamill is you know
we would
we would listen to him for the next 100
hours straight i mean
it's any any any sort of aspect that he
wants to relay
about that experience that he had is
sort of thrilling to us because it's so
pregnant and so enormous such a huge
touch point in terms of our lives on
every level artistically personally etc
so yeah it was a thrill and he he's an
amazing storyteller
has an amazing memory and um
it was it was a real thrill and a
pleasure just yeah i'll never i'll never
forget that experience
uh you guys produced 21 bridges and you
worked
uh very closely with chadwick boseman
obviously
all of us are completely devastated at
losing him at such a young age
um i know that it affected the entire
planet um can you maybe share a little
bit about what it was like
working with him off camera and maybe
what made him such a special person
sure yeah he i mean look he he's an
incredibly dedicated actor i mean
all the actors we work with especially
sort of in throughout the mcu
you know you're you're dealing with
actors who are at the top of their craft
and chadwick is certainly there but even
among actors who are among the
at the top of their craft he stood out
in
in his dedication to what he was doing
and his commitment to what he was doing
he's
he's a kind of actor and you can see
this through the various roles that he's
played throughout his career
his level of commitment to the character
it's
it consumes every layer of his being
and he really becomes the character out
of in a very method way
and i'll never forget just you know this
is a very simple detail but early on
when we were shooting civil war which is
his first performance as black panther
you know he would it was very difficult
for
us to working with him to find the
specific
um for instance african accents
the specific version of africa that we
were
trying to sort of craft with into the
fictional wakanda
and once he cracked that character and
found that accent
he stayed in that accent through the
entire
shoot even when he was off camera he
would only speak in that manner
as t'challa and it was and i think that
just speaks to the fact of how deeply he
had to build that character and how he
had to hold on to that character
throughout the entire process
in order to be able to perform it and i
think that's just it's just
incredibly admirable um when you find
somebody who sort of puts that level of
their being and their focus their
and their entire effort into what
they're doing and it translates the
screen i mean you
you feel something different when you
watch him perform not just as t'challa
but in all the roles he did so
yeah he was an incredible inspiration
incredible human being
just the height of professionalism and
artistry so
we could so grateful for our time with
him
he he had incredible integrity he was
very
thoughtful artistic
and elegant human being that was just a
pleasure to be around and a pleasure to
work with
and as aunt said you know not only was
he an actor he was a filmmaker he
understood
filmmaking he understood storytelling
and
yeah i think the thing that that's most
important to stress is
you know people who worked with him over
the last six years as
on several projects is that what he did
and the way that he dealt with his
illness was so brave
and and uh exemplified such integrity
because he put us up in a sort of
personal
agenda for what he knew was
a a you know a real moment
in time a real historical moment
in respect to what black panther meant
to people
and i i don't think he wanted his
illness to become the story he wanted
black panther
and this all-black cast to be the story
um and uh and that that's one of the
bravest things that
you know we've seen anyone do that's
that we've
dealt with on a personal level
i'm going to switch subjects and say
first of all thank you for um talking
about him
um really appreciate it uh i want to
jump into mosul which is the
your a project that you guys produced it
is now
streaming on netflix and um it's
fantastic
for people that are not familiar with
mosul
can you guys sort of talk about what
it's about and i just want to
say anyone who is now watching this you
should really watch mosul
it's so effing well done sorry for my
language
but um if you guys i'm not sure who
wants to maybe give like a log line or a
synopsis
mosul is a movie that we're extremely
proud of
uh it was one of the very first things
we did when we formed our new company
agbo
uh was to put our energy and our
resources
behind making this film mosul is a story
about a uh swat team
in mosul iraq that
was standing against isis during the
occupation of the city
and it was it was a very driven uh
and focused swat team though that uh
it was composed of it was based on an
article that
originally appeared in the the new
yorker by luke mogelson an amazing
article
this journalist embedded himself with
this swat team for six months
and stud uh followed them around and
wrote this amazing story about them now
this is a swat team in order to be a
member of this swat team
you either needed to have a family
member killed by isis
or you needed to have been physically
wounded by isis
so it was a very focused very driven
group of people
and uh the film sort of follows their
their story in terms of like how they
approach distangling
isis from their lives after isis is
in many ways destroyed and crushed
crushed their lives
and uh the movie is both written and
directed by matthew carnahan
uh it's an amazing film we're extremely
proud of it
uh the movie's shot in uh is uh is
entirely
cast with entirely arabic actors
it's uh shot in eric in the arabic
language
we tried to be extremely faithful to the
iraqi point of view
and telling the story and i think it's a
movie unlike anyone's ever seen before
where you have the heroes the
protagonists of the story
are middle easterners in the midst of
warfare in the middle east
and it's it's very inspiring and very
humanizing and an incredible thriller
of the film one of the things with agbo
is that you give a lot of first-time
directors
first-time feature directors their their
opportunity their break
and um so joe what was it about matthew
because for people that aren't familiar
with him he's a
brilliant screenwriter but he's never
directed a feature
and this is a very ambitious project
loaded with action
and as anthony said it's it's in it's
not in english
it's um it's dealing with really a hard
subject matter
um so talk a little bit about uh what
was it that said yo he can do this
i mean steven soderbergh and george
clooney produced our first
major features movie called welcome to
calm um well
the uh you know they held the door open
for us to get into the phone business
and so we feel like we department debt
to the university that
for other people and you know
it's so hard to get a movie made it
requires such an enormous amount
of lifeblood that um you need an
engine you need a creative engine behind
it who's going to
get the car started and drive it up the
hill uh and
you know we reached out to matt about
writing the script
uh uh and he read the article said he
cried when he read it
fell in love with the story he wanted to
tell a story about
middle eastern protagonists um you know
he is one of the best screenwriters in
hollywood
and we just knew that he had the
creative vision to execute this
um uh and you know we put together a
great
uh iraq team of filmmakers and
collaborators
who were he worked very closely with
subjugated his ego
and you know brought brought in this
team and and
you know and they they were there
working alongside him in a
in a very collaborative effort to bring
this as a
authentically to the screen as possible
so we're you know we're always
supportive of
of uh new energy new voices people who
feel like they have something they want
to say that they're passionate about
saying
and we'd work with matthew on some other
projects including 21 bridges and
and so we knew him and trusted him uh
and uh
and we're more than happy to support him
as a filmmaker
uh anthony i'll ask this of you um i'm
curious with you guys at agbo
how much are you going in early to the
editing room and watching early cuts and
how much is it sort of like
can you sort of talk about your
relationship as the studio heads
um you know looking at the material
that's being made
and how does that all work yeah very
much i mean look
the the the programming at agbo uh
we're only making a movie at agbo if joe
and i really care about it and really
believe in the film
so everything that we or the television
show and so everything that we're doing
uh we have a huge investment in on an
emotional level on a creative level
and we are participating in the process
you know
that being said we choose collaborators
in the manner that joe was just
describing in
the in the way that stephen soderbergh
and george clooney first collaborated
with us when they produced our
our first film there's a lot of trust
that
exists between us and the filmmakers
we're collaborating with
and we choose people because we believe
in them
so we give them a whole lot of autonomy
in terms of
how they're trying to what story they're
trying to tell and how they're trying to
tell it
and we look at it as our job to support
that process as best we can
um while at the same time we have a
strong point of view
on what what these stories are and why
they should be told so
it's it's a bit of it it's definitely a
very sort of engaged process but at the
same time i think
you know with other studios you're going
to get a much more sort of
artist-friendly and supportive approach
with us
because that's really the reason that's
who we're betting on in our
in our process we we bet on people we
believe in
and we support their vision and i think
you can see
the movies that we're making uh joe
we're going to jump into cherry now uh i
wanna i wanna start with
so after avengers end game you guys
could pretty much make any movie you
wanted
you had that juice you know because it's
the biggest movie of all time avengers
end game
what was it about sherry that said this
is what we want to make
as our follow-up it was a very
personal project for us um you know this
is a
book uh written by a gentleman named
nico walker
who grew up in cleveland where we grew
up he grew up in neighborhoods
very close to where we grew up i even
worked at the same restaurant that he
worked at at different times
so there was a close intersection
between our lives his life
his life happened to take a very
different path than ours he was a war
veteran
who um who had some issues uh uh
with uh with opioids and
uh and became a bank robber he then
wrote a fictional account
of of a similar character
who grew up in cleveland and had similar
issues
we have had people very close to us die
because of this crisis
we have people who are still struggling
with recovery are very close to
us so this is a very personal film for
us to make
um and you know the value
and the benefit of working on movies of
marvel scale
and that's commercial viability is that
it allows you to use your brand capital
to
get difficult subject matter made this
was a very difficult movie
it's got very challenging subject matter
and i just have to say holland's
performance in the film
is exceptional i mean he absolutely
shreds himself in the movie
i am going to concur um
just being blunt i i got to see the
movie to talk to you guys
and tom is incredible um and the
chemistry between
tom and i i want to say her name right
uh chiara bravo
is that how you pronounce it sierra
sierra i'm very sorry sierra the
chemistry between
tom and sierra is uh fantastic
can you sort of talk about because it's
it's their relationship in this movie
and that's the backbone of the entire
film anthony can you sort of talk about
their relationship and um and and gets
casting
them together
yes um and i just i i do want to mention
one thing about your last question in
terms of like
following up end game with the with
cherry i mean as you can imagine it
would
on one level it was a very it could be a
very daunting
uh proposition to like what movie we
would direct
next after after end game uh considering
the sort of
reception that film had in the sort of
cultural impact the film had
and i think the way joe and i found our
way forward from that moment with cherry
was just
a very simple emotional reaction we
responded so
strongly to the material it had such a
visceral
immediate uh it spoke to us so
viscerally and so immediately
that it really felt like this was a
movie we needed to make right now and we
jumped into it
um and at the heart of the movie is this
relationship
between two people at the end of the
movie
even though the film is about um sort of
coming of age
and it's a love story and it's um
it's a war film and it's a bank robbery
film and it's a drug addiction film
it's sort of it it's a big melange of a
lot of complicated
life experiences but the heart of it is
the love story
and the heart of it is the relationship
between the characters played by
tom and sierra and that was what we hung
the entire emotional arc of the film on
uh for as complicated as things get for
as desperate as things get the one thing
that remains in the film
and the remains for the characters this
connection that they have with one
another
and how they can rely upon that to to
move forward
uh despite sort of very daunting
circumstances
[Music]
uh joe one of the things about cherry
which i think is going to be
um which i think a lot of the people
that know your work might not be
expecting is
and i don't want to get too specific but
you said it um in
a vanity fair piece so i i feel okay
talking about is that there's
essentially six chapters in the movie
and you've
talked about what some of these chapters
are but the way you guys
shoot it with the use of color and
framing is so
different than what people might be
expecting from their marvel from your
marvel work
um can you sort of talk about the
aesthetic choices you made
um and the way you presented the
material
it's always you know you look at our
careers we always just we make very
personal choices
we pick projects that excite us that
aunt and i are excited to do together
you know we're a team we've been a team
for 25 years so
we have to find a way into the project
and you know we collected comic books as
kids and
we're very passionate about you know big
pop culture
entertainment but we're also very
passionate about um
uh you know smaller more challenging
stories
uh and we grew up on our tour 70s
filmmakers just like everyone else and
and
uh you know who who loves filmmaking and
you know this is a movie that really
embraces
style and tone uh in very unique ways
and you know the film is about his life
cycle
it's about a 15-year life cycle uh
and it's broken into chapters as you
described
where each chapter is shot almost as if
it were a different film
but they're all connected in a way and
so there's a gonzo element to it
but yes there's magical realism in one
chapter and then absurdism
and then brutal realism and then horror
and then you know black humor
and dark humor so it really um uh it you
know it really
covers a wide uh scope
of uh of experience um
both for the character and for the
audience uh and
each each chapter we made very distinct
cinematic choices from costume to
performance to lenses
the style of camera work to the way that
the camera moves
to music you know it's a very
you know hopefully it's not a jarring
shift for the audience but
there you know it does move and and
take you places that you're not
expecting from chapter
chapter and when you put it all together
as a whole
hopefully you get a surprising and
unique movie going experience
it just came out that this will be
premiering on
limited in theaters in the end of
february and on apple tv
in march i think people are really going
to enjoy this movie and tom's
performance
and i'm just gonna say congrats uh let's
move on to the next thing which is relic
um for people that uh that was that
relic got fantastic reviews and
um i don't obviously it hasn't been seen
by a wide audience but for people that
are just heard of relic maybe what can
you say about it and
why people should see it well it's an
excellent film
from another first time filmmaker
natalie erica james
who made some incredible shorts that we
saw
and you know we're fortunate jake
gyllenhaal brought us this movie
um so we're very fortunate to uh to get
to work on it with him
and it's uh you know our favorite kind
of filmmaking is is
are films that trojan horse
strong modern philosophical
social thematic ideas into them
while also entertaining you so they feed
your brain they feed your soul they feed
your heart all at the same
time this is a very elegant uh
horror film about uh dementia
dementia and it's um uh
it's it's wrought and difficult to watch
at times
uh and scary uh and you know embraces
all the aspects that we love about the
genre
we're also telling a very elegant uh
profound
tale of a family
of women three generations of women
um dealing with uh their grandmother
uh losing their memory and sense of self
when did you guys first hear um
obviously when you make a movie
any movie you're not exactly sure how
well it's gonna do but extraction i
believe
is either the highest viewed original
netflix movie of all time
or it's number two it's what it's very
very it's
very high up when did you guys find out
that it was such a huge hit
uh it was not long after it opened um
you know netflix
you know netflix tracks its own numbers
in a way that the
sort of outside netflix industry
people can't can't quite see but we were
getting strong indications from netflix
very early on
that interest in the film was extremely
high
and then when it when it finally
premiered on netflix
uh we were getting reports right away of
how well it was doing so
we had a pretty good indication through
the entire time that it was
both highly anticipated and then once it
started playing that it was
playing extremely well and it was in
fact that the most viewed
netflix film ever
sam hargrave the director did such an
amazing job
with the movie and especially with the
action set pieces
um anthony i'll do a follow-up with you
um he's another first-time
feature director that you guys took a
chance on
to make this movie um what was it about
sam that said
you know he can make this movie and have
you signed him for like a five picture
deal
yeah no sam is an extremely special
person
and an extremely special filmmaker um
joe and i have a long working
relationship with him
through our marvel work he started as uh
chris evans
uh stunt performer stunt double uh
sort of graduated to our stunt
coordinator
second unit director um and
we really believe we believed in him as
a creative voice as a visionary
and there couldn't have been he was the
best person
to deliver a film like this extraction
you know he's one of those people who
can deliver
um action at a virtuoso level that very
few people can
and we've been very fortunate to be able
to collaborate with him through the
years
in that manner in our own films that we
are directing and it was our thrill to
be able to support him
in the director position on this movie
he's a he's a really special talent
and yeah we look forward to doing much
more works
with sam and many more special films for
sure
uh joe this question is going to be for
you uh for people that don't realize
um you've spoken in the past um i'm
specifically gonna ask you about the
extraction sequel
uh because obviously huge hit and i know
you're working on it you wrote the first
one and now you're writing the sequel
um in the past you've talked about how
the sequel
could actually be a prequel featuring
david harper's character and chris
hemsworth character
um but you haven't actually said either
way what you're making
so why not at ccxp world maybe tease the
audience
are we getting a prequel or are we
getting a sequel
i'm still not going to commit because i
think it's more exciting to surprise
people
but i will say this we are working at
building out a universe
of films that uh that could potentially
um explore uh some of the other
characters from the first movie
uh and some new characters uh and see
the interaction
um you know as more historical
interaction
between the characters so um uh if if
you're more
if you're interested in david harbor's
character you just may
get to see him in a future extraction
film
so basically saying that david harper
might be getting an extraction movie
with chris hemsworth cameoing in it
you know in the in the traditional sense
of universe building
a potentially um we're trying to find
more interesting
ways to tell these stories and to
cross-pollinate them
we're big fans of of just you know again
forging new paths and narrative can we
go backwards and forwards at the same
time
can things that happen in the past
affect the movies that happen and
you know in the present um and
uh you know what are new ways to tell
those stories
uh and can we see different points of
view you know can
you know every every antagonist is their
own
is their protagonist in their own story
so can we see
their point of view how do they perceive
the world
um what makes them empathetic uh and i
think that that's
a that's a compelling element to that
extraction universe is
it is a global franchise telling global
stories uh
and and we'd like to diversify the point
of view of those movies
last question on extraction um do you
have an idea
when a sequel or prequel might actually
be in front of cameras
intention is to start rolling cameras on
extraction two
uh sometime this fall chris of busy guys
so we have to figure out a schedule
but that's the intent at the moment
so fall of 2021 that's right
got it i'm almost out of time and i'm
not leaving you without talking about
gray man
which is going to be your next movie
that you're getting ready to film
it's going to be for netflix it's a huge
netflix movie
for people that aren't familiar with the
material what can you say anthony what
can you say about grey man
grey man is a spy film
and i would say that for if you you know
for fans of the winter soldier
the gray man is uh similar in the sense
that we're trying to embed it
in very modern current
environment that we're facing on a
global level in terms of
of spy networks and the cia
and uh it centers around a character
called the grey man
played by ryan gosling chris evans is is
going to be appearing in the film as
well
as a co-lead uh playing the lead
antagonist
so it'd be fun to see chris uh in the
sort of opposite role of a captain
america
and uh we're just trying to be very uh
current with it in terms of speaking to
issues that i we feel like are sort of
feeding global anxiety at the moment
and finding a way like joe was saying
earlier how do you trojan horse um
really relevant issues into a very
exciting
thrilling genre package so for fans of
action
and and the spy genre it's going to
really deliver on that way in a major
way
and uh uh but at the same time it has a
lot of complex
uh social issues that are unfolding
right now political issues
joe can you talk about where and when
you are gonna be filming this movie
we start shooting uh at the end of
january here in los angeles
uh and then we have some work uh
overseas in europe
uh after that in the in the uh in the
spring how has
the pandemic impacted um the production
of this movie
was it originally maybe gonna be more on
location
in certain places how have you guys had
to adjust the script or story
based on the pandemic we have an
incredible team and netflix has been
really supportive of a very safe team
um it hasn't impacted our location
shooting i mean this is a big
global spy thriller and its intent is
you know it's gonna it it's gonna hit a
lot of different locations
um so and we're still we're still gonna
film in those locations so
we're um you know we're excited about
that because uh
it's really important to the
storytelling uh that
uh that we visit these different
locations one of the things
um i asked this is as just a so i love
imacs
um i think the format is incredible you
guys have used imacs on your movies in
the past
uh i am curious with like with netflix
um
netflix movies tend to get a limited
theatrical release
but then you know it's mostly being
watched at home
uh all over the world have you had any
discussions
with netflix about using imax cameras on
something like rayman
no we haven't talk talked about using
imax cameras
on uh gray man but we you know
there we do have a lot of discussion
with um
with netflix about what is possible on
their format
and new sort of versions and expressions
of what they've been doing
it's hard to go into in detail because
this is sort of like these these are
sort of preliminary
talks that are being explored but um
the ambition of netflix is is very large
and and that sort of dovetails very you
know
really well with what joe and i hope to
do on a cinematic level
not just with gray man but with other
films as well so
it's hard to get into it at a detailed
level but there's
there's a lot of innovative thought
going on uh
there uh joe you've talked about in the
past one of the things i think that
endgame did so well or an infinity war
is you had a longer running time
and one of those the things that happens
with a longer running time is
you get to explore smaller moments and i
think one of the problems with a
two-hour movie is
when you introduce a character in the
first act that person's either going to
turn out to be bad in the third act or
there's only there's certain narrative
structure things that happen in movies
that we're all familiar with
and that's one of the problems with the
two-hour running time
um i'm curious with grey man and with
netflix
one of the things netflix has done is
they they've demonstrated that they're
willing to release a three hour movie or
a three and a half hour movie with
irishman
and i'm wondering have you guys had
discussions with netflix on
gray man or other things where you want
to push the boundaries
of you know the typical movie where
maybe you want to make a three-hour film
or not just a two-hour movie
um has that been something you guys have
talked about
yeah i mean look it we're again it's
something we're exploring
all the time every project that we
tackle we try to think of a new way
to uh surprise people with our approach
um and can we you know crack a new
um aspect of of storytelling or modern
storytelling
we agree that the two-hour format is the
most predictive format
genres in particular are the most
predictive because
you know they're there's their concepts
that are baked in
that make them genre that you know if
you don't include them
uh you're not really working in that in
that
you know that realm of filmmaking so uh
um you know what we're doing at gray man
that's different
it's not gonna be about running time
it's not gonna be about um
the length of it but we're not gonna
answer every question
in the first movie this is being
conceived as a series of films
and again potentially branching out you
know where
we can follow other characters um but
we're not going to answer every question
in the movie
so you're going to finish the movie have
a complete story
but you're still gonna have questions
about the wider universe
and i think that's one way to break the
model a little bit
is to not give the audience everything
in one film
don't have a close-ended narrative have
an open-ended narrative
that's a chapter in a book do you
envision
that the follow-up movies would all be
held by you guys or is it one of these
things where
you might do one but it could be other
filmmakers tackling stuff in the gray
man universe
uh you know it could be other filmmakers
i mean we we love it
you know we love what we're what we've
been prepping love the cast
uh but you know we'd love to tell
multiple stories and
schedule the pendant you know we might
not be able to handle everything
uh um so we love to bring new voices and
we also get excited about that
we like producing as much as we like
directing because we like being
inspired uh and surprised by other
filmmakers we like
we like um collaborating because aunt
and i have been doing it our entire
lives
so it's it's not we're not afraid of
collaboration we embrace it
and it's something that excites us
because uh you know you can get
locked into ideas as a filmmaker and
perhaps the you know most exciting part
of our entire careers is when we were
working as executive producers in
television
and directors were constantly coming in
to direct episodes of tv
tv shows that we were producing like
community
and you know you get to you so rarely
get to interact with other directors
you just get inspired by the way that
they work
it can be completely different than the
way that you work there's no guidebook
to the craft of directing everyone kind
of you know develops their own process
based on uh you know life experience so
um
it's a it's an exciting aspect
filmmaking
is when we get an opportunity to work
very closely with other directors
my last question is going to go to
anthony um anthony when i spoke to you
guys
i forget when you both talked about how
you had um i you had three films that
you wanted to make
back to back to back and i'm curious if
that is still the plan
we still know like what is after gray
man
i mean do you sort of have that figured
out you just haven't announced it yet
um what what what is the plan
yeah we look we we don't have to figure
it out in the sense that we can announce
it yet
there still is um a bit of a
development process left in order to
make those movies real
but yeah our look at our our directing
appetite is enormous we love directing
uh we're in a great place right now in
our careers and we have amazing
collaborators you know our
partners at agbo are uh chris marcus and
steve mcfeely
uh you know who who we made all those
marvel movies with and we've got some
really special
films uh that we've been developing
together
that again we're not right ready to
announce yet
but uh hopefully in the next few months
uh we may
we may be able to and yeah they'll be
coming right after great man
um i could ask you guys a million other
questions but i'm just going to say
thank you for your time um and obviously
before we end i just want to give a huge
thank you to our friends at omelette
and everyone at ccxp that is watching
around the world um for tuning in to
ccxp worlds
and also to joe and anthony russo for
giving us
uh some of their valuable time
thank you so much you guys have a
fantastic night
and everyone in brazil over god
[Music]
[Applause]
you